welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we want to talk and
investigate a bit more
length contraction we have seen length
contraction a few times already in this
class we have derived it i have seen it
in application
um
but you want to get some sort of feeling
to how how can we actually understand
what's happening to the objects
later in this section in this video
we'll talk about
a another paradox spacecraft on a rope
so let's get to it so the situation here
is
you know as we have seen a few times
already we have alice being at rest and
bob is moving with the velocity v
and what we are interested in
is this object here
which might be a
a
a rod of some sort uh you know you can
think about the spacecraft if you want
but a specific object which address has
a length lb
for alice this object is launched
contracted and it appears shorter
so now
what happens now if
bob accelerates from its velocity v
to a velocity v plus delta v with
respect to alice
how does the acceleration occur
and how can we understand then the
further shrinking of the spacecraft
bob tries really really hard to
accelerate such that
all elements of this rod or spacecraft
are being accelerated
simultaneously in this framework you can
think about splitting up the spacecraft
into small elements they're all getting
a little bit of a kick a little bit of
an extra momentum at the very same time
so
if now alice observes the same situation
we find that
she looks at the spacecraft and because
the leading clock in a spacecraft in
bob's spacecraft legs
she observes that the spacecraft's back
is being accelerated first
and because it's accelerated first
she observes that the spacecraft shrinks
just a little bit because of the
additional velocity
that's kind of an interesting picture to
think about
you know how we can understand length
contraction and how we can understand
length contraction once there's
acceleration involved
okay
so the next question now the next topic
here in this video
is
the spacecraft on the rope on a rope
paradox
this was phrased by bell in the 1960s
50s and 60s
he was working at cern at the time and
roaming the corridors discussing with
his colleagues the situation here
is related to the one we just discussed
but slightly different so let me explain
so again we have alice as an observer
observer in a reference frame a
observing two reference two spacecraft
they're identical spacecraft they have
the same engines and they're separated
by distance d
so now alice gives a signal
to both spacecraft simultaneously in her
reference frame to accelerate
at the same time
such that the distance between b and c
remains constant
so they are asked to accelerate such
that the distance remain constant
so the question now is
um
when those two spacecrafts are connected
with a rope
will this rope break
so i'll let you to think about this a
bit
and come up with your own answer
in the meantime
this is not such a hard problem actually
in order to keep the distance constant
for a
the distance in the bc reference frame
in the reference frame of the two
spacecraft needs to expand
so l a so the distant as observed by
by uh by alice by our reference frame a
is equal to one over gamma the distance
between the two
plates and for this to stay for l a to
stay constant while there's acceleration
going on
l b c needs to increase that's why the
volt will break